Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Google
Maps Developers team.
I'm coming to you from Mountain
View, California, at
the Googleplex to give
you another Google
Maps Developers shortcuts.
This is an episode on how to
build your first iOS app using
the Google Maps SDK for iOS.
To help you out, I've uploaded
a project to GitHub and to
Google Code called
Hello Map iOS.
So let's take a look at that.
This is the Hello Map
iOS on GitHub.
You'll see here we outlined
the requirements.
The basic requirements are you
have the latest version of
Xcode, you download the Google
Maps SDK for iOS, and you have
the iOS 6.0 SDK.
That's all outlined in this
doc and on our developer
documentation.
Now the steps to get started
are, first, you're going to
clone the project on iOS.
So here I'm going
to hit Clone.
There I've got get clone the
project, and I'm going to look
in the directory and I see
I have Hello Maps iOS.
And I'm going to double-click
on this Xcode project file.
And look, I have the project.
OK.
Now I'm going to explore
this here.
I've got to create and add the
key to the project, and that
is going to go into this
HMAppDelegate file.
So I am going to go over to the
Google APIs console, where
I've created a project.
Just called it iOS Map Apps.
And you'll see here I have
the Google Maps SDK
for iOS turned on.
Then, I'm going to switch over
here to API access and I'm
just going to show you
the process for
creating a new key.
I create the iOS key and I
say com.example.hellomap.
You can use your own project
identifier, but for this
purpose, do this.
I click Create, and you'll
see it added an API key.
So I'm going to copy that, and
I'm going to go into the
AppDelegate file, and I'm
going to add in the key.
By the way, if you're copying
down my key, I'm totally
deleting this at the end
of this episode so
don't even try it.
But you'll see there's
still an error.
We haven't actually added the
framework to the project.
So I'm going to go over here.
I downloaded the framework to my
desktop, and I'm just going
to click on the framework file
and drag that over to the
project, add it to the
frameworks in my project.
And then I'm going
to click here--
copy items into the destinations
group folder,
click Finish.
Almost there.
Almost done.
So now I click on that
and pull up a context
menu, Show in Finder.
And I am going down to
Resources, opening that up,
and you can see the Google
Maps bundle.
I'm going to drag that
into the frameworks.
Uncopy copy items into the
destinations group folder
because it's already there,
click Finish.
OK.
What's the next step, you ask?
The next step is run it
in the simulator.
Click on Run.
And there you have
your first map.
Yay, awesome.
OK.
Two common mistakes--
one is you don't add the
framework, two is you don't
add the API key.
If you find everything loaded
but you're getting a blank
map, add the API key.
Oh, one other thing that
actually just came up today.
Check the deployment target,
which is if you go into the
project navigator, you click
on Hello Map, and then on
Targets, you select Summary.
Look at the deployment target--
make sure that you
are using one that you actually
have installed on
your system.
So we do require for development
that you
use at least 6.0.
You actually have that installed
on your system, but
we do support back to 5.1 for
actual deployment, so it will
run on devices back to 5.1.
I discovered this when I was
working with somebody who
didn't have 6.1 and I had baked
6.1 into the project.
You may need to change it back
to 6.0 if you don't have 6.1
yet, or just get 6.1.
OK, that's it.
If you have any questions,
as usual, Stack Overflow.
And we look forward to seeing
you in the next Google Maps
Developer shortcut.